KEITH DANEKIND: Hi.
I'm Keith Danekind.
Welcome to Cloud OnAir, live
webinars from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
And today, I'm going
to talk about how
to connect APIs with existing
identity management systems.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform,
and we'll have Googlers
standing by to answer them.
So let's get started.
So here's our agenda for today.
I'm going to do a brief
overview of Apigee Edge
so you can see what
that looks like.
Then I'm going to talk
about identity management
and how you can integrate
that with your existing APIs.
So how would you take
your existing APIs
and add them so that
they can authenticate
against your identity
management system,
both on the front
end on the back?
After that, we'll do
questions and answers.
So let's get started with
an overview of Apigee Edge
and what that is at
a very high level.
So this describes the
philosophy for Apigee Edge.
Apigee has seen a repeated
pattern of success
with its customers, and
it's driven by how they
think about their API program.
And it requires a shift in
how you think about this.
So traditionally,
we think about this
from an exposure point of view.
You can just expose a
service and be finished.
But thinking about it from
the end user's point of view
leads to much better results.
Our successful customers
start from the user,
thinking about what that
user's experience will be like
and then working
backwards from there.
Providing the application
developer with great APIs
will reduce the complexity
of creating new applications.
The developer is free to
focus on user experience
and iterate on a few
different designs.
The API team makes this
possible by providing
easy to use APIs with consistent
interfaces and security.
The API team builds an API
facade on existing services,
abstracting away
the complexities.
Hide away all that
enterprise stuff.
Apigee Edge makes it
easy for your API team
to build great APIs.
And Apigee Edge also makes
it easy for developers
to consume those APIs.
It also lets you measure every
aspect of your API program.
So here's Apigee Edge.
Let's talk about what's inside.
Apigee Edge is a single platform
with three conceptual parts.
API Services allows you to
expose and manage services
to an API.
Developer Services
provides a portal
where application
developers or API consumers
can learn about your APIs
and request access to them.
And Analytics Services lets
you measure every aspect
of your API program.
So let's look at these
three parts in a little bit
more detail.
So for API Services, this
is where we build APIs.
So this is the
bulk of what we're
going to be doing when we think
about integrating with things.
On the left we're going
to have applications,
maybe a mobile application,
a web application,
or some sort of partner system.
These applications
make API calls.
They're going to send
HTTP requests in.
Apigee Edge lets you pass
that request straight
through the back-end system.
Or you can change
anything about it
in the headers, the
URI, or the body.
You can even do intelligent
routing based on the caller.
Maybe there's different
back-end systems
you want to send them to.
You can also manage
the flow of traffic
by imposing rate
limits or quotas.
And you can apply caching.
So you have complete
control over the request
and the reply in there.
When the back-end system
returns a response,
you can send that response
straight to the application
or change it around as needed.
For example, you
might want to reduce
the payload to a mobile client
or transform XML into JSF.
So after you build
some great APIs,
you want to make it
easy for your developers
to discover them and
start using them.
The developer portal
gives you a place
to put your documentation
and tools that
let your developers
register for access.
Developers can try out your
APIs from the documentation.
They can fill in data
fields, see what the request
and response looks like.
And the Developer
Portal is going
to greatly reduce the friction
when getting started with APIs.
So this is your one stop
shop for all your developers.
Rather than having
meetings with them
or sharing PDF documents
or anything like that,
you've got a nice
website where they can go
and they can get
registered and see docs.
So after you built a few APIs
and your application developers
have discovered them and
started to send you traffic,
it'd be great if you could
measure your API program.
The analytics system
in Apigee Edge
allows you to measure every
aspect of your API traffic.
You can measure
operational details
like response time and frequency
of different types of errors.
You can find things that are
interesting to your business,
like where are people located
when they call your APIs
or which applications are
sending the most traffic?
Maybe it's interesting to
see what type of client
they're using.
Are they on Chrome?
Or are they on Firefox?
Are they on iOS or Android?
You can get details like
that in Analytics Services.
And you can add your own
custom metrics in here.
So if you want to measure
something that's specific
to your program, grab that out
of the request or the response
and connect that with some of
the existing out-of-the-box
analytics and get full
detailed reports on that.
So let's talk about
our demo today.
We're going to talk about how
to integrate with an IDM system
or identity management system.
So there's a few types
of authentication
we might need to consider
when we're building APIs.
We may just need
to identify which
application's calling our API.
Is it a website application?
Is it an iOS app?
Is it an Android app?
But in addition to knowing which
application is calling our API,
we might need to authenticate
the end user who's
actually using the application.
Maybe we've got
something in there
that's a little more sensitive.
Maybe It's a banking application
or something like that.
Also, our back-end
services might
require some authentication.
And that might be
different from what
we're doing with the users.
So in a lot of cases,
we'll want to separate
front-end authentication
from back-end authentication.
We might have a variety of
different authentication
mechanisms on the
back side, but we
want to provide a
single consistent way
of authenticating
when you call an API.
We want to hide away
the gory details
of the back-end authentication
from our API consumers.
And you might have multiple
ways of authenticating calls
to that back-end
system, depending
on which back-end system you're
calling and when it was built.
So we want to provide a
facade on the front that gives
consistency to all of the APIs.
So let's consider
an example where
you need to authenticate
end users using
an external identity
management system
and call a back-end service
that uses a service account that
requires a username and
password in the form
of basic authentication.
We'll prompt the user for
their username and password
and we'll store the username
and password in the back end
in Apigee's key value map.
So in this case,
what we're doing
is, on that
left-hand side there,
we're going to ask them for
a username and password.
And on the right-hand side, it's
a completely different username
and password to get
into that system.
The identity management
system could be anything.
It might be an
off-the-shelf thing
that you've already
got in place.
It might be a cloud-based
identity management system.
Might be your corporate LDAP.
In this case, I'm
making it generic
so we can look at examples
of how this can work.
So here's what our
authentication flow
might look like.
Let's consider a request.
Let's consider a request
from the users in there.
Now look at the application
on the left-hand side there.
Let's look at the
business flow first.
When the user comes
in, they're not
going to have an
authentication token.
So they would go down to
that authentication flow
and get a token,
The authentication
flow would talk to an
identity management system.
And then, at the end of that,
it's going to generate a token.
So if you've got that token,
you flow through that top path
easily.
So that token is sent
as a request header.
We're going to check that token.
We're going to apply a
little bit of traffic control
in the form of
that spike arrest.
That will keep us from
calling too quickly,
keep the back end from
getting overwhelmed.
Then we're going to
remove the header.
And that's going to remove that
security header because it's
not required for the back end.
We'll grab the credentials
for the back end
using the key value map.
And then we'll set a new
basic Auth header in there
before it goes to the back
end using that identity.
So one identity on
the left-hand side
in the form of that OAuth
token, and one identity
on the right-hand side in the
form of a user basic header.
So where do you get that token?
That's where the authentication
flow on the bottom comes in.
So let's assume the
application connects.
It doesn't have a token.
It's going to get
back an HTTP 401.
And that means they're
not authorized.
So that application will know
to call out to a token flow
where it can get
an access token.
So we pass in a username and
password to the authentication
flow.
That is going to call out to
an identity management system.
So that first blue
arrow there is
a call-out to identity
management system.
And we're going to assume it
has an HTTP end point on it.
So we call out to that.
If the username and password is
good, it'll return a 200 to us.
And if that works,
we'll continue.
If not, that second thing in
there, BadAuth, will fire.
And that will return
an error letting
the application know that the
username and password wasn't
good.
So if that does
work, we're going
to collect some things from
the identity management system.
There might be some things in
there about what their role is.
And we could use that
later on for authorization,
figuring out what
they're allowed to do
and what they're
not allowed to do.
From there, we'll
look up the keys
that are specific to this API
that the user is requesting
a token for.
And then we'll
generate the token.
And that's an OAuth token that
will be returned to the user.
So then that's returned
up to the application,
and the application
then has the token.
So if you want an
analogy for this,
think about when you go to a
festival or something like that
and you're given a wristband.
And that wristband might
be a different color
depending on what day it is
or what you're allowed to do.
Maybe folks over 21
are given one color
because they're allowed
to go and drink,
and other folks are
given a different color
because they're not.
So there's a credential
that's presented
in the form of a driver's
license or something like that.
And then that is
exchanged for a token,
which would be the wristband.
And the wristband gives
you different entitlements
based on what it looks like.
We can use that
analogy to describe
what this flow would look like.
So let's dig into the API
proxy and see what that looks
like inside of Apigee Edge.
So here's Apigee Edge.
If you haven't seen this
before, let me jump out
and give a little bit of a tour.
So when we first come into here,
we're greeted with this screen.
This is where we're going
to build API proxies.
So in this case, we're playing
the role of the API developer.
We also have
application developers
that'll consume our APIs.
That's a different
group of developers.
So let's focus on
API development.
What I would do
when I come in here,
I'm going to click
on API Proxies.
I've got a list in
here of APIs proxies.
If I want to build a new one,
I can come up to this button
and hit Plus API Proxy.
A few different
options in there.
Most commonly, I'm going
to build a reverse proxy.
I might have a spec for it.
If I have an open API or
Swagger spec for that,
I could build my API
proxy using that.
Maybe I've got a SOAP Service.
I could come down and use that.
There's a wizard in there to
convert SOAP to REST, REST
to SOAP.
I can digest a Whistle, and
it'll make a conversion thing
in there.
No Target allows us to create
a stubbed out interface.
So we're going to come
up with the response
right there in the proxy.
We've got Hosted
Functions and Node.js.
They're both going to allow us
to host something in Node.js
inside of Apigee Edge.
And then Proxy Bundle would let
us import an existing zip file.
So in most cases, I'm
going to do reverse proxy.
We come in here.
Proxy name, base path,
and then an existing URL.
So I would walk
through this wizard.
And then, at the end of it, I
end up on a development screen.
I'm going to show you
guys a pre-built one.
So let's go back and look at
our identity management example.
So in this case, I'm
calling a back-end system
that's an employee directory.
And it requires a
username and password.
And it's a system
It's just basically
a service account.
But on the other side, I
want to authenticate my users
against our identity
management system.
So I would end up on a
summary screen like this.
This is the URL that I'll call.
And then, this is
the back-end system
that it's going
to call by proxy.
We'll click over on
the Develop tab here
and we'll see what's
going on in there.
So here's the flow I was
talking about before.
What we're going to see in here
is there's a number of policies
up here.
And then we've got
some code down here
on the bottom that configures
what those policies do.
So policies that are available.
This is the request flow
and the response flow.
We can put whatever
we like in here.
If I click up here,
we'll see that there's
a number of policies
for traffic management,
for response caching,
working with caches,
populating them, invalidating
them, warming them
up, that sort of thing, all
kinds of things with cache,
either through a policy
or programmatically
through an API call.
Lots of policies
around security.
We're going to use the
OAuth policy in here.
A lot of things
around mediation.
So converting between formats,
returning custom error
messages, things like that.
And then custom extensions.
So if we want to do things with
Java or Python or JavaScript,
we can do that.
And I'm going to make use of
the service call-out in here
to call out to our
identity management system.
So let's go through here
and see what's in here.
So first thing
I've got in here is
I'm going to check and make sure
that they have an access token.
So I want to verify their access
token and make sure it's valid.
So if it's not valid,
we're going to send back
an unauthorized error.
And if it is valid, flow will
continue over to the right
here.
So first thing to do is
we've got an OAuth 2.0
policy in there.
And then, this configures it.
I've got it in Verify
Access Token mode.
There's a bunch of different
operations it can do.
And I've chosen to have
it on Verify Access mode.
Spike Arrest is next.
So Spike Arrest
will reduce or it'll
limit the frequency at
which somebody can call.
So I've limited this
to 10 calls per minute.
If they call faster
than that, I'm
going to return
an error message.
You might also use a
quota policy in here.
That's a fixed number of calls.
So one would control the
rate at which you can call,
and the other would be a
fixed quota of number of calls
per day, per hour, per minute.
The quota tends to be
more business related,
what you've agreed
with the customer.
And then the spike
arrest is really just
to protect your systems
and keep somebody
from just hammering the system.
Next thing I'm going to do
in here is remove the header.
So we've sent in an
authorization header
with that token.
But we don't want to send
that to the back-end system
because it doesn't understand
it, it doesn't need it,
anything like that.
So what this is going
to do is actually
remove the header
from the request
before it sends that request
onto the back-end system.
So remove the
authorization header.
And the next one is we're
going to do Get Credentials.
So Get Credentials in here,
what that's going to do
is it's a key value
map operation.
And we're going to look up
the username and the password
for the back-end system.
So we'll have those as
variables in the system,
and then we can use
them in the next step.
These are stored
in a key value map.
So there's an encrypted
key value map in here.
And that's under
the Environment tab.
We'll find that
over on this side.
And I'll take a
look at that later.
This will set a basic
authentication header.
So we're going to take
that username and password
that we got in
the previous step,
and we're going to create
a basic Auth header.
So that's a base
64 encoded string
of the username and password.
And that's what our
back-end system understands.
And then, that goes to
the back-end system.
And we should be logged in
and we should get data back.
I'm not doing any
processing on the return,
but I could reformat the
response or anything like that
if I want.
So let's take a look
at this step here.
Where did we get these
credentials from?
So let's go over
here and take a look.
I'm going to click on
Environment over here.
And what we'll see
in here is that we've
got a few different settings.
So we've got different
caches we can have.
They can be associated with
different environments.
We can have flow hooks,
references, target servers.
But I'm going to look
at key value maps.
That's what's interesting to me.
So I have lots of passwords
for back-end systems in here,
and I keep them stored in here.
So this is where they all are.
You can look them up by value.
So look up the key, and
then you get back the value.
And that's where my employee
directory, username,
and password, they're
going to be stored in here.
And that's where I get them.
I could have
different credentials
for my different environments--
my production environment,
my test environment,
QA staging, whatever
my environment happens to be.
I can have a map
for each of those.
So if you have
different credentials
for those different
environments,
we'd automatically be able to
get the right one depending
on where the thing's deployed.
So that's where that came from.
So that's an example of how
we might build a simple API
proxy that would integrate
with our existing identity
management system.
So that was the business
flow, and that's
what checks the token.
But where did we get that token?
Where did that come from?
So let's take a look
at the token flow
and see where the token
actually came from.
So I have another
flow in here that is
going to return tokens for me.
And in this case,
we're going to do
some checking of that
actual username and password
before we return a
token to somebody.
So here's the flow for that.
I've got a spike arrest in here.
And that's going
to prevent somebody
from calling us too quickly.
But if we notice down here
under Proxy Endpoints,
we've got a few different
flows down here.
So this pre-flow is
called all the time,
no matter how I call this proxy.
And then there's conditional
things in between there.
And then there's a post-flow
that is called unconditionally
after that.
In this case, if I call
this with an HTTP post
and I'm calling /token,
this logic gets executed.
So this is the actual flow
we're going to get the token.
So first thing here is we're
going to authorize the user.
So in this case,
what we're doing is
we're going to send in the
username and password that
was sent to us.
We're going to send that over
to the authorization system
and have it check this for us.
So the URL for the
system is down here.
And then here is the
actual body of the payload
that I'm going to send in.
So I'm going to do an HTTP post.
I'm going to send in the
username and the password.
And then I'm going to
get back a response
and I'm going to store
that in IDM response.
I will allow 15 seconds
for that to happen.
If that doesn't happen, we're
going to get a timeout error.
So that's the actual
call to the system.
If it fails, if it returns
something that's not a 200,
we're going to have this fire.
And it's going to say, "Invalid
username and password."
You can put whatever you
like in there, whatever
makes sense, maybe
some guidance on how
to deal with that or hints
on how that might work.
So as long as it returns
OK, that'll be skipped
and we'll go on to here.
So there's a session
token that's returned.
And I want to grab
that out of there.
So that will give me some
information from the identity
management system.
It's going to return a session
token and a few other things.
But basically, what
I'm counting on here
is that I got back a 200 from
the identity management system.
And then, if there's any
other metadata in there,
I'll grab that out.
In this case, it's a session
token, and we'll take that.
In this next step
here, we're going
to set some keys for our API.
So that's where we're going to
set our API keys for the token
we're going to generate.
And then, finally, this
generates the token.
So we're doing a
password grant type.
And we're going
to build a token.
And we're going to
return that to the user.
And we'll take a look
at that in a second
so we see what that
flow looks like.
So the username
and password are--
I'm sorry.
The username and
the session token
are the two attributes we're
going to stick on there.
When we generate a
token with Apigee Edge,
you can stick any kind of
metadata you want in there.
So this might be
identity information
that you grabbed from your
identity management system,
what department they work in,
a billing code, a partner ID,
anything like that.
These get populated as variables
whenever that token flows
through the system.
And we can use that
for dynamic routing.
We could use it for
dynamic rate limiting.
We can control
what they're doing
and how they are routed
through the system and things
like that.
So that generates our token.
So that's our two flows.
One of them is the
business flow that's
going to connect to
the back-end, system,
and it requires a token.
And then this flow
is the token flow.
And it'll generate tokens for
us so that we can send them
to the application and it
can be used to call things.
So let's look at what those
look like from the command line,
so to speak.
So in this case, here's my
identity management system.
What I've got here is a
tool that lets me just
call REST-based end points.
So I'm going to call up
the identity management
system, the tokens, and then
the actual business app.
So the identity
management system,
what I like to do
when I'm building this
is I'll pull up a tool like
this and I'll prototype my API.
So what does it take to
close that back-end system?
What can I send in there
and what will I get back?
And how is that going to work?
So if I send in a username
and password to this,
this is what I get back.
I've gotten back a 200 OK,
and that means that I'm OK.
If I come in here and I
change my username in there
and I send that in, we're going
to get back a 401 unauthorized.
Those are the two responses
I can get from the system.
And the password here,
it's using a variable
so that we can't
see the password.
So that's the identity
management system directly.
That's what we're
doing that call-out to.
The token flow where
we're calling Apigee,
we're going to send in
the username and password.
It'll send it out to the
identity management system.
If it gets back that
200, then it continues
and it returns us a
Apigee OAuth token.
And that will look like this.
So here's our token
that comes back.
We've got a few extra
things in there.
We've got the user ID in there.
We put that on there.
And then we've got a
session or a-- let's see.
Where is it in here?
It's a session token.
So there's a session token that
comes back from the identity
management system.
We might use that for logging.
What's important to me, though,
is this access token right
here.
And I'm going to grab
that and copy it.
And then here's
our business flow.
So this is a simple application
that lets us look up employees.
And we need to have a
basic Auth header in here.
And if we don't have one, it'll
say that we're not authorized.
So we can come in here
and put a value in there.
And then we'll paste our
token value in there.
And when we have a token,
we'll see employees come back.
So what this does is we can
look up an employee by name.
And I'm looking for
anybody named Smith here,
and that's what I'm
seeing come back.
So the flow is complete there.
We pass in a username
and password,
and in exchange for that
we're given a token.
And then we use that
token in the business flow
and we pass that as
a header on here.
And that's what gets
us into the system.
So simple example of how we
might do security mediation.
So we're going to use one set of
credentials on the application
side, and we're going to use
a different set of credentials
on the back-end or system side.
Nice pattern for putting a
facade on an existing system.
A lot of times,
dealing with security
is a big burden for developers.
And being able to have
consistent security for all
of these things is going to
make it a lot easier to do.
So let's look at
another example.
So a nice example, username
and password for the back end.
But what if you're
using Google Cloud?
What if you need to have
a service account for all
of your different things that
you can do in Google Cloud
and you need to get
credentials for that?
So a somewhat more
complicated use case.
But once we've
mastered this, it's
easy to do for any
service in Google Cloud.
So when you want to
access a system in GCP,
you need to have an
OAuth token for that.
And in order to get
that OAuth token,
you've got to send
in a JWT request.
And it has to be signed
in a particular way.
And once that's sent in, we'll
get back that OAuth token.
It's got a timeout on it.
And we can continue to
send that as a header.
So same pattern here as
we saw in the last one.
But in this case, we're
going to do an Apigee OAuth
token over here on
the left-hand side.
And then we're going
to do a GCP token over
on the right-hand side.
So what we're doing in this
case is the authentication flow
will be exactly the same.
We're going to
authenticate the end user.
And we're going to talk to the
identity management system.
And that is going to generate
a token as that very last step
and then return to the client.
And then we've got to
verify key on there
as the first step in
the business flow.
We're doing some rate
limiting to make sure they
don't call too quickly.
Then we're going
to check a quota,
make sure that they
didn't exceed that quota.
And we've got some
response caching in there
to speed things up.
What's new in here is
we have a thing that
says GCP Authorization.
And that's a shared flow.
So what you can do
inside of Apigee Edge
is you can have a
series of flows,
and you can have some
that you'd like to share
between different API proxies.
I build a lot of things that
talk to Google Cloud Platform,
so being able to reuse my
authentication is really nice.
So I'll put that
into a shared flow.
And I include that in
multiple APIs proxies
without having to
build it every time.
So what we're seeing here
is there's a shared flow,
and there's quite a
few steps in there.
The last step in here is
the one that's important.
Just like we saw in
the last example,
we need to have a
header in there.
We need to have a bearer token
and an authorization header.
And that's the value that we
got back from the Google Cloud
identity management system.
So it sends us that
token, and we're
going to insert a bearer
token in there as a header.
And that's the
last step in here.
The other steps are
what lead to that.
So I'm going to
call out to this.
And the first step
in here is a cache.
If I already have that
value in cache-- maybe
I got it a few minutes ago.
It lasts 30 minutes.
I put it in in-memory cache.
I'm just going to pull
it from that cache.
If I don't have it in cache,
the next steps are to go get it.
So in most cases, what's
going to happen here
is we're going to pull
that out of cache.
All these steps will be skipped.
And then, the last
step will execute,
and we'll stick that
header in there.
If we don't already
have that value,
then all these things in
the middle do execute.
So we're going to look up
some keys and secrets that
allow us to talk to the
identity management system.
We've got a Java call-out
in there to build that JWT
and encrypt it the right way.
We're going to make a call-out
to the identity management
system.
We're going to extract some
things from the response that
comes back.
We'll adjust the timeout,
make a little bit shorter.
And we're going to have
the cache have a time
to live that's a
little bit shorter
than the length of the token.
Finally in there, if it's
not in the right format
or we get an error, we're going
to return an error code there.
We'll put it in the cache so
that next time we can find it.
And then we'll set a variable so
that it has a well-known value.
So that's what that
flow looks like.
A little bit more complicated.
I'll go into detail in a
minute on how this works.
So end result of that
is we've got a header,
and then we can call
it whatever we're
entitled to with that service
account inside of GCP.
So let's look at the API proxy
and let's see how I built that.
So let's take a look at the
shared flow for that GCP spec.
So in this case, I've
got shared flows in here.
I'm going to come
in and look at that.
So here's GCP Auth.
So when we're doing a
shared flow and Apigee,
this screen's a
little bit simpler.
And these aren't intended
to be used standalone.
They're always included
in something else.
They become part
of another proxy.
So let me flip over
to the Develop tab,
and we'll take a look
at what's in here.
So a bunch of steps in here.
So first one is the cache.
Do we have it cached?
If it's already cached,
just pull it out of memory
and return it.
Skip the rest of it.
So that's what's in there.
We're going to look for
a value called GCP token.
That's a key for it.
If we don't have that, we
need to get a few things.
We need to get some
credentials in there.
So we've got the JWT issuer.
We've got the privatekey.pem.
And then this is
our Java call-out.
So this is calling a JAR
file that's stored over here.
And we're going to
pass in some values.
We want to do RST56 for
the encryption algorithm.
We're going to pass in
some values about who
the audience is, what
the expiration time is,
and then what the
claim scope is.
So this will allow
us to call BigQuery.
And we're going to get
a token back that's
very specific to
this and gives us
entitlements to certain
things inside of GCP.
So here's the actual call-out
that will call the URL.
So Google API's
Auth2 before token.
So that's the way
of programmatically
getting a token if it's
not an interactive flow.
If this was an end user, they'd
be greeted by the Google login
screen and they'd go through
their credentials and things
like.
That this is the programmatic
way of doing that for services.
So we will call out to that.
We're going to send
it as form encoded.
We're going to send in just the
right form parameters in there,
that JWT that we created.
And then we're going to store
the response in token response.
And we're going to
consider success
either a 200 or 300 code.
We'll get what we need out
of there, which is the access
token and the expiration time.
So that's the response
that comes back.
And what we're doing is we're
actually pulling things out
of the response in there.
We'll adjust down
the expiration time
and shrink it down so
it's a little bit less
than the expiration
of the token.
There's some error handling.
And then here we're going
to put it into a cache.
So we're going to go cache that
token so that we don't have
to do this every single time.
Finally, we'll set
it as a variable.
And then this is the thing that
gets called every single time.
This is where we actually
insert that header in there.
And that's what's going
to make it so that we
can call the back-end system.
So that's a typical flow of
what we might do in here.
And that's how we would go in
and generate the GCP token.
So let's take a step back
for a minute and talk about,
why are we doing all this?
So why not just call the
authentication system
every time?
So in particular, this flow.
Why use an Apigee token in here?
Why bother with this
when you could just
call the authentication
system with every single call
and it would give you
a credential in there?
So the idea here is, when
we want to speed it up--
so we want to make it so that
it's faster to call the system.
So in each case, if we
have an Apigee token,
it's about a millisecond
to check that thing.
So pretty fast.
A call to the
authentication system
might take a little bit longer.
But more importantly,
this Apigee token
that we're generating
down here has a lot
of metadata associated with it.
It's going to tell us which
API product they're using.
It's going to tell us
who the developer is.
It'll have any of
those attributes
that we've attached to it.
And with those, we can
do dynamic routing.
We can send people to
different locations.
We can rate limit them based
on their relationship with us.
So we get a lot of
additional features
with that that are much
better than if we were just
simply checking a
username and password.
So that's why we're
going to do that.
And that's why we're going to
cache it and do it that way.
So that's our two flows.
Let's look at an example
of an application
or two applications
that use these and see
what those look like.
So the first one I showed
was the employee directory.
And remember, in this case we've
got a username and password
for the front end that's checked
against the identity management
system, and then a service
account for the back.
So if I want to come in and
check my employee directory,
it's going to require
me to authenticate.
So let's say I'm searching
for somebody named Smith.
Is going to say I need
a username and password.
So I need to enter
that in there.
And what it's going to do is
go out and get that token,
and then my application
will have a token.
And when I search,
I get back results.
So if I want to search for
somebody else, I can do that.
I continue to search until
that token is no longer valid.
So that's our basic
idea behind that.
So what does this look
like behind the scenes?
What's the flow for that?
This is a simple,
single-page web application.
It's written in JavaScript.
And what I've got in here,
the interesting parts of it
are down here where I'm going
to go and actually call and get
a token and where I'm going
to do the business search.
So here's the basic search.
We're going to do URL
in there for the API.
It's going to get back
some data and then draw
that on the screen.
Down here is update token.
So that's the process for
going and getting a token.
We're not storing any
credentials in here.
So this is a
JavaScript application.
It's in a web page.
Somebody can easily hit
View Source on this.
So we don't want the
credentials stored in here.
We want to be able to go get
a short lived access token.
That access token's
only good for 30 minutes
or whatever we set that
session time out to.
So that's the application
for the password on the front
and the service
account on the back.
This application is
going to call BigQuery.
So what I've got in here
is an application where
I can check historical weather.
There's a few sample
data sets for BigQuery.
One of them is historical
weather for North America.
So I can look at
weather for any city
and I can check what the weather
has been for the last 100 years
or so.
What I did in this case was
I looked up at San Francisco
and I wanted to see what the
weather was like in 2015.
So two things are
happening in here.
When I call this, it's
going to do some geocoding
and look up the location
that I put in here.
And then it's going to return
a list of weather stations
that are in that area.
I can supply it with
a year, and then it's
going to go and retrieve
weather for that data.
So this showing me high
temperature data from January
all the way through December.
So what's interesting in here
is I'm sending in an API key
on this, and then it's
doing that flow in there
where it's going
to go get a token.
It's going to have
a service call-out,
and it's going to get a token
that's appropriate for calling
BigQuery with read only access.
So that's what's happening
behind the scenes in here.
I've applied some rate limiting
to this so if I call it
too quickly it's going to shut
me down and things like that.
But I get everything I
need in the application.
It's a nice mix of things.
I could authenticate people who
are going to call this however
I like.
So there's my rate limiting
kicking in to prevent somebody
from calling up to quickly.
But that's the general
idea behind this.
So that's our applications.
And that's what they
look like and that's
how you could build
something like this.
So if you want to
learn more about this,
if this was interesting to
you, a few different resources
you can look at.
You can go to Apigee.com and
sign up for a free trial.
When you get to the page there,
there's a nice big red button
up in the top that says,
like, try it for free.
And that can generate
a Google Cloud or a--
I'm sorry, an Apigee
account for you.
And you can try out these API
proxies, build your own things,
and see how it works.
We have some hands
on enablement.
If you want to try out a virtual
API jam or an on site API JM,
it's a great way to learn.
And an API Jam is a
hands on workshop,
either a half day or full day.
And what we do is we go
through this with your team,
and you guys and go
through some exercises
and teach you how to build
basic things in Apigee
and learn how to
use the product.
There's a number of product demo
webinars similar to this one.
So take a look at those
and find topics for those.
I've got all the URLs
posted on this screen.
If you want just
general information,
take a look at
Apigee.com and see what
you can do with the product.
Here are some stories about
what other customers have done
and how you can use Apigee to
build a fantastic API program.
At this point, we're going
to take some questions.
We'll be back in just
a second for questions.
OK.
Looks like we've got
a few questions here.
Let me read a few
of these, and we'll
talk about what's in here.
So first question I've
got is, "Can you integrate
with Active Directory?"
So I hear that a lot.
A lot of people are standardized
on Active Directory.
So if you can reach your Active
Directory, we can work with it.
So as long as you can reach it
through HTTP or a Java call-out
or JavaScript or Python,
you can absolutely
integrate with Active Directory.
The next question, I
guess somewhat related,
"What if our identity
management system
doesn't have an HTTP interface?
Will this still work?"
So what do we do in
the case of that?
A lot of things--
I'm thinking like
Oracle Access Manager,
Tivoli, some of those--
they don't necessarily
have an HTTP interface.
If they have a Java library,
you can use that, call an API,
as long as you can get
back some sort of signal
from that back-end thing
that says this user is OK.
So if there's really
any way to call it,
we can use this same pattern
to integrate with that identity
management system.
"What about 2 factor
authentication?"
So what if you're using
2 factor authentication?
You've got to enter
a text code or you're
using Google Authenticator
or some other system that's
going to ask you for that
second piece of information.
How do you do that?
Well, same story in here.
When we call that identity
management system,
it will usually push out that
second factor to the user,
and then they can
enter it into here.
We'd need to provide
an interface for them
to be able to enter it or
some way to respond to that.
But no problem with 2
factor authentication,
and definitely encouraged
to keep things more secure.
We've got another
question on here.
Somebody's asking and say, "I
still have a lot of questions.
Is there a way to
set up a meeting
to go into more detail?"
Absolutely.
So go to the Apigee web page,
Apigee.com, and look on there
and find a link on
there to talk to sales.
And we can set up a
meeting for you guys.
I can come there or somebody
like me on my team can come
and we can set up a meeting,
answer specific questions,
do a full in-depth demo, and
talk about your use cases.
Is there any limit
on the expiration
for tokens and token refresh?
So no limit on that.
You can adjust what the
refresh time and what the limit
is for the tokens.
So you can specify
what the time to live
is, how many refreshes they
get, and things like that.
And that would be set to
whatever you want to set.
So the next question,
somewhat related from that,
is, "Is there an industry
standard for how long an OAuth
token should be valid for?"
So no real industry
standard around that.
But talk to your security folks.
They usually have
requirements on this.
What I've seen is a
lot of folks will match
what they have on a website.
So whatever their session
timeout is for their web site,
a lot of times their API is
going to be the same thing.
30 minutes, 60 minutes for
things that are more sensitive.
Longer if they're
not that sensitive.
So that's what I've
got for questions.
And that's all the questions
that we've got right now.
So stay tuned for
the next session.
It's going to be how to
enhance your G suite sweet
efficiency with Chrome.
And we're going to broadcast
live from our New York office.
So thank you very much
for attending today.